lucia quiere regalar dulces en la fiesta
de su hermano menor se le ocurre
colocarlos en varios recipientes y
necesita elegir aquellos donde quepan
más dulces encontró estos dos
recipientes que tienen forma de cono y
de cilindro pero no sabe cuál le caben
más tomó la medida de cada uno y ambos
tienen una base de 10 centímetros y una
altura de 20 centímetros de qué manera
lucía podría saber a cuál de los dos
recipientes le caben más dulces bien
podemos calcular el volumen de cada uno
a partir de las medidas que tomó lucía
mira si los comparamos con otros cuerpos
geométricos vemos que se parecen mucho a
prismas y a pirámides sólo que el
cilindro y el cono tienen como base un
círculo
vamos a intentar calcular su volumen
empleando las fórmulas del prisma y de
la pirámide y veamos qué sucede
recordemos que para calcular el volumen
de un cuerpo geométrico hay que calcular
el área de la base por su altura y en el
caso de la pirámide después de
multiplicar la base por la altura vamos
a dividirlo entre 3 comencemos con el
cilindro si usamos la fórmula de un
prisma rectangular el volumen es igual
al área de la base por su altura así que
primero debemos conocer el área de la
base como la base del cilindro es un
círculo usaremos la fórmula de pi por
radio al cuadrado para calcular el área
para obtener el radio la fórmula es
diámetro sobre dos porque el radio mide
la mitad del diámetro como el diámetro
es igual a 10 centímetros solo lo
dividimos entre dos y tenemos 5 bien
el radio es igual a 5 centímetros
sigamos con la fórmula para calcular el
área y sustituyamos valores como pi
equivale a 3.14 entonces el área es
igual a 3.14 por 5 al cuadrado
5 x 5 son 25 entonces nos quedaría área
igual a 3.14 por 25 y así obtenemos 78.5
perfecto el área de nuestra base es de
78.5 centímetros cuadrados continuamos y
calculemos el volumen recuerda que la
fórmula es área de la base por altura de
esta manera tenemos que la base es de
78.5 por 20 de altura nos daría como
resultado 1500 70 centímetros al cubo
perfecto
esta fórmula nos ayuda a conocer la
capacidad del cilindro
vamos con el cono y usemos la fórmula de
la pirámide para calcular el volumen que
sigo a la base por altura sobre 3
nuevamente hay que encontrar el área de
la base pero como nuestro cono tiene la
misma medida que la base del cilindro ya
no será necesario volver a calcularla ya
sabemos que su área mide 78.5
centímetros cuadrados como ya tenemos
todos nuestros valores vamos a
sustituirlos en nuestra fórmula para
encontrar el volumen el área de la base
es 78.5 por la altura que es 20 sobre 3
resolviendo nuestras operaciones
tendríamos que 78.5 por 20 es igual a
1.570 luego mil 570 dividido entre 3 nos
da como resultado 500 23.300 33 y así
tenemos que el volumen de nuestro cono
es
523 punto 333 centímetros al cubo que
bien usar las fórmulas de un prisma y de
una pirámide nos ayudó a calcular el
volumen del cilindro y del cono así
podemos concluir que al llenar nuestro
cilindro de dulces éste tendrá mayor
capacidad se me ocurre algo como el
cilindro y el cono tienen la misma base
creo que podemos compararlos entre sí de
esta manera
ya viste qué pasaría si llenamos el
cilindro de dulces con el cono dentro
crees que si pasamos los dulces del
cilindro el cono se llene por completo
te invito a comprobarlo